how ironic that in the week Britain
hosted the Commonwealth Heads of
Government Meeting news hits that the
children of the Windrush generation from
the Caribbean whose parents were invited
here as Commonwealth citizens with the
right to live work are being denied
settled status in the middle of what's
supposed to be a celebration of our
renewed more equal relationship with the
Commonwealth this utter disgrace hardly
sends a message of confidence about the
trustworthiness of British leaders and
the promises they make calls for an
amnesty for those affected miss the
point these people are not here
illegally there should be no need for
costly legal fees or requests to produce
old documents the government simply
needs to honor the original agreement
apologize and offer assistance to anyone
affected we are all being denied health
care or the right to work or been
wrongly deported failure to do so will
diminish our links with Commonwealth
it's time to show a bit more respect to
our elders and stop playing games with
Commonwealth citizens as well as British
citizens it occurs to me perhaps anyone
who's living on different planet if you
not aware you mentioned briefly the
Windrush just to explain these are
people as you said who came to the UK
from the Caribbean starting in 1948
Windrush yes indeed the Windrush was
from the name of the ship the Empire
Windrush it brought initially workers
from Jamaica Trinidad and Tobago they
answered a call from the government for
struggling industries such as
agriculture and mining under the 1971
Immigration Act all were given
indefinite leave to remain so important
to your conversation there's around
500,000 people this affects from the
corner the country many have been
wrongly identified as illegal immigrants
because they don't have the official
paperwork now to the meat of the story
I've always been proud to be British
even though I'm half British was my late
dad this is an absolute scourge on
Britain I cannot for the life of me work
out how I'm living in a country where we
have been unable to deport egyptian-born
hate preachers Algerian born terrorists
and Romanian killers we are unable to
get them out of the country and yet in
some instances we can't with look at
people who
here who have worked for 50 years
invited here who have paid their taxes
we've denied them cancer care we've put
them in emigration centers we possibly
possibly possibly one-offs their life
because of the emotional pressure that's
not verified but possibly certainly a
suffered emotional strain and it is a
situation that besmirches every single
political party because it was an idea
or part of it that seemed to initiate
under labor it was carried under the
under the coalition nobody emerges any
credit it is an absolute bloody disgrace
disgrace disgrace and I think the thing
that upsets me most so you know I'm one
of those people in the year after and I
often debate on this issue and a lot of
the time I actually disagree with her
sort of stance where race is concerned
and I never used that R word willy-nilly
but I think in this case if we want to
know what institutional racism looks
like it's this because it's funny how
there are nine million people in the UK
who don't have a passport and it's funny
how when it comes to this issue we are
looking at people of color and and
actually when you look at immigration in
general with particularly Commonwealth
immigration people from countries like
Australia we unit majority white
countries yes can have ancestry visas
that's not available to people from the
Caribbean countries and because of
slavery the majority of those people
have white British ancestry before I
yield I spoke to Trevor Phillips on my
radio show who I think we'll all agree
is a force for good in matters such as
these and he said that unfortunately
these people just do not have a voice if
it was different ethnic groups or
different religious groups they have and
it's horrible to say so they were
effectively written off this is and as I
say and this is absolutely shaming
before I bring the rest of everybody
else saying can I show David lamby's
speech in the comments this week how
many have been denied help under the
National Health Service
how many have denied ventures how many
have lost their job this is a day of
national shame
and it has come about because of a
hostile environment policy that was
begun under her prime minister if you
lay down with dogs you get fleas and
that is what has happened with this
far-right rhetoric in this country I
agree and I think as you say the timing
could not be worse yeah just when we are
as a country trying to show it I would
face to the world as global Britain it
looks like we've turned in on ourselves
even more so I mean we also need to talk
about the fact that the Home Office has
managed to destroy all these landing
cards of funny that the legal immigrants
were invited in and I think we need to
look now beyond this crisis and the 3.7
million EU citizens who must be looking
at this shambles in absolute abject
despair I know somebody who's been sent
an 80-page document to prove that he has
a he's been living here but just yeah
this is about this how are they going to
be able to continue to live in this
country if people who are invited in
who's the government has actually
destroyed the evidence of 200 of their
immigration previous government a
previous government of course yeah
it's it's just shocking and but let's
let's put a human face on it because
we've we've heard a lot of numbers and
actually David Lammy was calling for
numbers let's hear from Michael
Braithwaite who's 66 who came into this
country in 1961 I feel that I am British
and you can't take that away from me
you know this is my roots this is where
I belong you know and I had that dark
dark feeling of not being part of and I
think that was after being part of the
school and part of the team and part of
everyone and to have that taken away
from you you know you know step of a
finger it was a dark place my whole
world was turned upside down
so Michael braithwaite's been termed now
an illegal immigrant and we should say
that the Prime Minister Theresa May has
spent a lot of the last two or three
days apologizing for this she done
enough but I mean in my view I mean
people have record the fact that when
she was Home Secretary in
go home office it was basically you know
she said we have to make this country in
a legal and on an alien environment a
hostile environment for illegal
immigration because illegal immigration
is unpopular let's not forget it but
also the problem here is these were
illegal yes I just got so good Michael
Braithwaite has now quite rightly been
clear to just underscore your point
forward bring them why does the Prime
Minister just slam a desk and say
they're all staying we bring up Michelin
you haven't mention which i think is
shameful the cost of this right now it's
been calculated that it costs about four
hundred pounds for the admin to show
that you can stay in this country do you
know how much you're charged twelve
hundred now to some of these folks who
have been driving buses or working in
the 1200 pounds why why we making eight
hundred quid out of each case look at
what's reason mayor has said about this
as well I want to dispel any impression
that my government is in some sense
count me down all kind of wealth
citizens particularly those in the
Caribbean I take this issue very
seriously the holy secretary apologized
the House of Commons yesterday for any
anxiety today but that's still not as
far as massive common sense issue with
his whole thing for me do you know he
just reeks from top to bottom
you know the paperwork go missing the
fact it was even brought up in the first
place you know these people as the
British as anybody sat on his table does
not mean so it's absolutely no way they
should even be in the forefront I mean
let alone labeling people return the
other it just shouldn't be an issue full
stop for me which is you know it's a
shame totally me I mean my heart breaks
for everyone I can't imagine there's
someone knocking on my door turning up
at my door in the middle of the night or
where I work and going right you prove
your residency or else I'd be like oh
how can only just about found my mobile
phone sometimes never mind the paperwork
dating back years and years and years
and you need four pieces of
identification for each year you've been
like this often that haven't an asset
for me this whole thing is just sheer
incompetence because if you look at why
this is happening is
unintended consequences in there of some
immigration a new immigration policy and
this is why this is now coming to light
and I think how could you have a
grievance the tougher immigration policy
I do agree with its offer immigration
that's for illegal immigrants so I agree
with the policy that was introduced I
think this is an abscess did you agree
with around saying if you're illegally
get out or you risk arrest did you agree
with the burns well I thought they were
a little bit odd to say the least
didn't I do things no but I do think
that what they're gonna be cool and
gonna be you know it does wrong much
about what we're doing is a country
we've decided to draw a line in the sand
and we're gonna place that line he
decided comes in a new house do not mean
that's all this is saying help create
this hast on do not accept that help
create this hostile just feel so sorry
for the people I've listened to lots
people on the radio I've read lots of
stories and I think it is so awful to
literally be when they've been put in
detention centers and all of the
quarters but I just think well where is
your brain in these three banker I just
think where is your brain so actually
not keep the required paperwork as a
government I'm talking about I'm not
talking about the people but as a
government why haven't you got like
Central Records so if you say a lot is
this person well they did that's what I
mean they about it's ridiculous I know
what you and I want to go around the
table if this was a business
the chief exactly would almost certainly
be good I'd be surprised if he or she
clung on for this level of shambles
amber Rudd is still in post I appreciate
some of it happen not on her watch but
we knew about this in November
newspapers were breaking stories
gentlemen of the Guardian
congratulations on outstanding report
obviously is in the running for
journalists and campaign of the year
- it merited using chippings it yeah I
woulda thought he or she's probably
facing the exit is leaving at all his
amber rod split for purpose does she
stay you Rachel
absolutely I mean this was not her
shopping running since November you've
just said yourself to me that's not the
question the question is not about
whether or not we fire and the run is
about questions about it we just need
the government to come out and say
anybody nine million people without
passports five hundred thousand people
who came over without proper paperwork
it's not the real answer I know it's not
who we are as a country but ID cards I
mean honestly this means that obviously
their home office isn't fit for people
in it for purpose when it comes to the
paperwork therefore annoyed in order to
save people from going through this sort
of nightmare we need some actual ID you
know if we need a central database it
does not work the ID card is it's
another day the ID card for me do not
wait up it with we're straying away from
the football in someone needs to kick it
right